news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
okay i don't want to spend a ton of time
on this but i want to cover two really
crazy reactions to the biden harris
campaign
sort of coming together in the last 24
48 hours that we've seen
the first is remember that wacky
fox news host former judge jeanine pirro
she sort of suggested last night that
she knows
something about how joe biden is not
actually going to be on the ticket by
november she suggests
something is going to happen to joe
biden
between now and november although she
doesn't actually say what let's look at
the clip
well i i have a lot of thoughts the
first thought that i have jesse is
for some reason i just have this feeling
that joe biden isn't going to be on the
ticket
i have a sense that something's going to
happen before
the election and he's not even going to
be on the ticket so don't even ask me if
he's going to make the four years
but let me just tell you a little bit
about what i saw
so immediately the questions start is
this a death threat
is janine pirro trying to subtly suggest
to her audience that someone
do something about joe biden is this
merely
some kind of allusion to a health issue
she believes joe biden's going to have
between now
and november is puro merely drunk again
and unable to cohere during her program
it's not
totally clear um the the sort of most
dangerous and sort of insidious
interpretation of this would be the
stochastic terrorism type situation
now she's of course not saying anybody
should do anything but the idea of
stochastic terrorism
is that given a large enough audience if
you
plant an idea that something
could be done that it becomes
statistically likely
that you would influence one person to
do
something there the first time that we
discussed
stochastic terrorism on this program was
back in
i don't even remember what year when
glenn beck
was ranting and raving about the tides
foundation he had all sorts of ideas and
conspiracy theories about the tides
foundation and it actually led to
a particular guy getting weapons and
was was stopped on the highway i bel i'm
going from memory i believe it was in
california
on his way to attack the tides
foundation and of course
glenn beck would not be held legally
responsible for that if the if the
shooting or bombing or whatever were to
be carried out but the guy who was on
the way
said yeah i watched fox at the time
glenn beck was on fox news i watched
watch fox news and watch glenn beck
and it's it's sort of uh it's a
mathematic it's a statistical thing
where
if 0.01 of an audience is likely to
actually do the violence
that is implied by a host if you have
100 people in your audience it's
unlikely to reach the threshold of one
person going and doing something if you
have a thousand people it's unlikely
but once you get to an audience of a
hundred thousand of five hundred
thousand of a million two million
even a small likelihood of influencing
someone
becomes likely to actually influence 1 5
10 15 people to go and carry out an
action so that would be like the most
uncharitable
interpretation of what janine pirro is
doing here
what what is unbelievable
is that this is happening on one of the
country's largest
three cable news networks and it's
happening in prime time
and at least as far as we know right now
there's no
repercussions for it there's no blowback
whatsoever from the perspective of fox
news
now in terms of whether anybody would
really be able to do anything to joe
biden joe biden has secret service
protection kamala harris
does as well now and secret service is
good at their job in terms of protecting
people
and i imagine that joe biden's safety is
is well handled so that would point more
to the idea
um that she's floating of some kind of
health situation for joe biden so that's
number one
in terms of the just wacky reactions to
biden harris
getting a lot of attention in the first
24 to 48 hours after the announcement of
kamala harris joining the campaign
let's now go to number two uh which
uh we we are not now but tomorrow i'm
going to go
to number two which is uh birtherism
birtherism is back it's less urgent so
we we will discuss it tomorrow but
no shortage of that and of course
birtherism with barack obama was hugely
racially tinged
and what a surprise lo and behold kamala
harris whose
father is jamaican and mother is indian
now
being hit by very similar birther like
questions about whether she's eligible
to be vp
or president were she to be in a
position to
replace joe biden and we're going to
discuss that tomorrow